ein quantencomputer führt zu hause
massentauglich kompakt autark genau das
ist das ziel eines österreichischen
forschungsteams und den fachleuten ist
nun ein spannender meilenstein gelungen
sie haben einen prototypen entwickelt
der in zwei server schränke pass statt
ein ganzes labor zu füllen gibt es also
schon bald quantencomputer schritt zu
hause klicks um science and future hier
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
kanten computer gelten als das große
ding der zukunft sie sind nämlich in der
lage aufgaben nicht nur unglaublich viel
schneller sondern auch deutlich
effizienter zu lösen als herkömmliche
computer das alles basiert auf super
spannenden quantenphysikalischen
phänomen computer könnten viele komplexe
probleme der menschheit lösen und
anwendungen in zahlreichen verschiedenen
bereichen sind denkbar
in der medikamentenforschung für
berechnungen in der logistik der
finanzwirtschaft bei künstlicher
intelligenz oder datensicherheit ein
quanten internet über das gespeicherte
informationen über große entfernungen
ausgetauscht werden könnte sogar eine
neue ära der kommunikation anleiten zu
schön um wahr zu sein
doch es gibt ein aber die anlagen sind
nicht nur extrem empfindlich sondern
auch gigantisch groß tatsächlich fühlen
sie ganze labore und von bright
nutzbaren massen anfertigungen sind wir
trotz intensiver forschung weit entfernt
der große traum also vieler
forschungsteams quantencomputer die
massentauglich sind doch die
anforderungen sind nicht ohne
die technologie müsste nicht nur von den
endnutzer rinnen und endnutzern selbst
und möglichst leicht bedient werden
können nicht nur spezialisten dürften
also mehr an
zudem müssten die quantenrechner
deutlich kleiner werden und
weitestgehend automatisiert laufen
dieses spektakuläre ziel verfolgt auch
ein forschungsteam von der universität
innsbruck die fachleute sind dabei einen
autarken modularen und kompakten
quantencomputer zu entwickeln dabei ist
den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nun ein großer erfolg
gelungen in einer aktuellen studie
präsentieren sie den prototypen eines
industriell herstellbare quanten
gut dass die fachleute haben hierbei die
technologie die bisher ein ganzes labor
gefüllt hat in zwei server schränke
gepackt also auf deutlich kleinerem raum
untergebracht dennoch gelang ein
sicherer und fehlerfreie betrieb oder
für quantencomputer fast fehlerfreien
betrieb wie ist das möglich und ob
quantencomputer schon bald
massentauglich werden die antworten auf
all diese fragen gibt es in diesem video
fest steht schon seit vielen jahren hat
die quantenwelt die wissenschaft in
ihren bann gezogen das phänomen der
verschränkung erlaubt es den zustand von
teilchen die atome ionen oder photonen
zu koppeln
ganz egal wie weit diese voneinander
entfernt sind und sobald sich der
zustand des ein teilchens ändert gibt es
auch beim verschränkten partner teilchen
einen zustand wechsel und genau das ist
die basis für viele super praktische
anwendung der quantenphysik und davon
ist der quantencomputer nur eine
quantencomputer rechnen anders als
klassische computer nicht mit bits die
den wert 1 oder 0 annehmen sie basieren
auf den sogenannten kubitz die beide
werte gleichzeitig annehmen können und
so viele mögliche lösungen zur selben
zeit durch rechnen können oder anders
gesagt in einem klassischen computer
handelt es sich bei der kleinsten
recheneinheit um bits in einem
quantenphysikalischen system übernehmen
beispielsweise ionen also quantenbits
oder kurz kubitz diese aufgabe so auch
beim franken computer des
forschungsteams aus innsbruck die
kumpels wenn wir von vielen lesern in
einer art falle festgehalten und
angestrahlt und somit in bestimmte
zustände versetzt so kann dann mit den
kumpels gerechnet werden
doch die herausforderung dabei das
system muss quasi komplett von der
außenwelt abgeschirmt werden um
zuverlässig zu sein
aufwändige maßnahmen sind im labor also
notwendig um solche konten experimente
vor einflüssen von außen abzuschirmen
vor zwei jahren 2009/10 hatten google
fachleute einen quantencomputer
entwickelt der mit 53 kubitz im 2/100
sekunden eine aufgabe gelöst hat für die
ein gewöhnlicher supercomputer tausende
von jahren benötigt hätte damit war die
quanten überlegenheit erreicht einen
quantencomputer war zumindest bei einer
sehr speziellen aufgabe herkömmlichen
supercomputern überlegen viele fachleute
bezeichnen das als den beginn der
quanten
computer ära eine große herausforderung
muss aber noch angegangen werden und
zwar möglichst fehlerfreies rechnen die
fehlerquoten liegen immer noch im
zweistelligen bereich und so tüfteln
expertinnen und experten von google ibm
intel und viele weitere an praktisch
einsetzbaren quantencomputern auch die
europäische union ist am start am
forschungszentrum jülich in nordrhein
westfalen soll bis ende 2021 ein
quantencomputer mit bis zu 100 kugeln
entwickelt werden mitte juni diesen
jahres 2021 bei europas erster
quantencomputer eingeweiht worden der
ultra schnelle rechner der firma ibm
nach stuttgart laut bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel ein zitat wunderwerk der
technologie und sie muss es wissen sie
ist schließlich wissenschaftlerin das
ziel im wettstreit mit china und den usa
bestehen zu können doch auch hier zeigt
sich wieder wie wuchtig diese
technologie bislang noch ist der
quantencomputer bei stuttgart verfügt
über eine grundfläche von drei mal drei
metern bei einer höhe von drei metern
ja das passt jetzt hier nicht unbedingt
ins studio oder überhaupt in irgendein
büro oder eine wohnung anders bei dem
nun entwickelten prototypen aus
innsbruck dieser modular aufgebaute
könnten computer ist im vergleich dazu
schon fast klein denn er passt in zwei
server schränke genau genommen in zwei
gängige 19 zoll server racks wie sie
eben in rechenzentren üblich sind das
ist schon verdammt klein und macht
theoretisch die verwendung in kleinen
büros oder rein theoretisch sogar zu
hause möglich dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam zitat uns ging es nun
darum die technologien auf
kleinstmöglichen raum unterzubringen und
gleichzeitig die in der industrie
üblichen normen und standards zu
erfüllen
das system besteht aus mehreren
eingekapselt modulen und diese haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
dann übereinander gestapelt in einem der
beiden server racks ist die quanten
technik untergebracht hier ist unter
anderem die steuerelektronik zu finden
wie auch die ionenfalle hierbei handelt
es sich um eine vakuumkammer in der 24
verschränkte kalziumionen in einer
magnet falle gehalten werden doch auch
dieses system ist äußeren einflüssen
gegenüber sehr empfindlich und so nutzen
die fachleute aus innsbruck spezielle
vibrations- dämpfer und methoden der
abschirmung zudem benötigt laserstrahlen
die kugel dann in verschiedene
energiezustände zu versetzen erfolgt
wurden diese laserstrahlen im zweiten
server turm der im experiment mit dem
ersten über optische und elektrische
leitungen verbunden war doch wie stabil
und zuverlässig kann dieser kleine
prototyp rechnen genau dieser frage sind
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in verschiedenen tests
nachgegangen und die ergebnisse
überzeugten dazu heißt es von dem
forschungsteam zitat wir konnten zeigen
dass kompaktheit nicht auf kosten von
funktionsfähigkeit gehen muss auch die
fehlerquote stellte sich als gering
heraus weder äußerliche magnetfelder
noch vibrationen hatten das experiment
in größerem maße beeinträchtigt wir
erreichen eine zuverlässigkeit von 99,8
prozent pro adressierte einzelnen gatter
insgesamt rechnet die fachleute sogar
mit 24 googles dabei lag die
zuverlässigkeit ohne weitere korrekturen
bei 54,4 prozent die anzahl der
verfügbaren quantenbits ist tatsächlich
unter anderem auch ein entscheidender
faktor für den industriellen einsatz
eines quantencomputers die deutsche
bundesregierung hatte kürzlich erst das
ziel formuliert demonstrations-
quantencomputer zu bauen die mehr als 24
voll funktionsfähige quantenbits
verfügen
dieses ziel wurde also erreicht denn bis
zu 24 jahren konnten beim innsbrucker
prototypen individuell kontrolliert und
erfolgreich miteinander verschränkt
werden und das nächste ziel steht schon
auf den plan dazu sagt einer der
beteiligten forscher thomas monz bis im
kommenden jahr wollen wir das gerät mit
bis zu 50 individuell ansteuerbaren
quantenbits ausstatten bis zum jahr 2022
soll es nach dem wunsch des
forschungsteams zur marktreife kommen
das langfristige ziel sei es zitat eine
wachsende anzahl von quantencomputern
aufzustellen die bei raumtemperatur in
einer normalen büro umgebungen arbeiten
in standard 19 zoll racks installiert
sind und über eine gewöhnliche
wandsteckdose mit strom versorgt werden
so das forschungsteam aus österreich
langfristig gesehen könnten
quantencomputer somit also breiter
verfügbar werden und zudem auch deutlich
vielseitiger einsetzbar auch in normalen
rechenzentren könnte das rechnen mit
googles dann also funktionieren und zwar
ganz ohne spezielle kenntnisse
ob es aber irgendwann auch mal ein
quantencomputer für zu hause gibt
das bleibt weiter fraglich
höchstwahrscheinlich kommt es aber zu
synergien zwischen klassischen computern
und kanten computern und letztere werden
wir vor allem da nutzen wo sie besonders
gut sind und hier könnt ihr nochmal
diesen absolut historischen moment
erleben sensationeller meilenstein
google hat quanten überlegenheit
erreicht anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren einfach mit diesem roten
knopf ihr unter jedem video kostet
nichts und macht schlau bis dann bleibt
dran